warum nehmen wir heute ein Video im Bett
auf ja Luca wird demnächst only Fans
machen herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen nicht lachen Challenge Sand und
ich reagieren mal wieder auf tiktok
bevor wir allerdings mit dem ersten
tiktok reinstarten würde ich sagen
Sandra was machen wir Luca und ich gehen
auf Tour oh ne wir sind in Köln München
Hamburg und Berlin es gibt nur noch
Tickets für Hamburg und ein paar
restliche für Berlin der Link ist in der
Videobeschreibung oder goelt einfach
Dick und Doof Tour weil sonst muss ich
halt die restlichen Tickets kaufen und
ihr wollt nicht dass ich haben bin bist
bereit Harry Potter nein ein Mädchen
Essen und so wie es dann gehört habe ich
dann gesagt so lass die Rechnung einfach
aufteilen die guck mich so an sagt so
I und ich dachte da kommt noch was weil
keine Ahnung so wir Kannen uns jetzt
noch nicht so gut war erst Date dachte
kommen aus Berlin oder sowas weil da die
Leute sagen mal
lalala z. so wie ich i sagen die weißt
was ein i ist ja habe ich gesagt was I
die so i d habe ich mal gueguckt was den
i ist was ist di woher kommt dieses i
hier mich ein i wenn Leute benutzen so
schlimm dieses Wort Frauen ja wenn die
so Harry Potter Brille haben und sind
[Musik]
schlau ich liebe as Videos die Lage in
Ukraine hat sich etwas beruhigt ah nee
das ist ja hier in Deutschland Kurv
lüdenscheid
also Menschen sind so woher woher nimmt
ihr das Alter aus welchem Arschloch dass
ist so an sowas Dent da hast Du
tatsächlich recht J frag für
Bundeskanzler ich habe die Idee
Bundeskanzler zuer ich bräuchte kein
Geld davon zu kriegen also ich verzichte
aufs Geld ich würde die christlichen
Werte nach vorne bringen aller
cduel einach zu
[Musik]
krank
mein Bruder was bestellst du Burger es
ist Karneval wie woll ich zu dir kommen
[Musik]
du es kann sein dass die erste nicht
lachen Challenge nicht
lache kennst du das bei allen ti ist
drunter dieser komisches auf GI auch oh
nein ich
blute seh einfach aus wie Brüder der
rechts sieht aus wie du der rechts sieht
aus wie du junge guck mal die n welches
Level hat ein
Rathaus welches Level ich grüße gasm und
gut diger so
süß ja
wieter so
h oh mein
Gott guck mal wie der genießt Alter aber
in der Welt besonders in einer
Fußballwelt sind sie sehr sehr sehr
individuell jeder jeder sucht sich
selbst oder sich selbst sie kümmern sich
nicht um deine Momente deine schwierigen
Momente deine Probleme familiäre
Probleme krass ne der Deutsch gelernt
der Typ kann alles oh mein
Gott krass hat der deutsche
Familie krank ja sein Sohn ist Deutscher
hallo scroll
zurücker zurück wegen Fitnesstipps
genommen ne
C love
love war als in echt im Bus krass aber
der hat überlebt
don't take life to seriously nobody gets
outive anyway das heißt nimm das Leben
nicht so ernst kommst eh nicht Leben
[Musik]
raus dummen scheiß
Krieg
diger was für eine
Maschine krass ne warum schlägst du
nicht ist den W world
[Musik]
Guinness diger safe was ist der im
W W world
ginness wie bitte im wck World gness
genau W ist den
ja
Alkohol einfach Köln statt dem no Nut
November habe ich eine viel bessere Idee
für euch nämlich den no noise november
und da haltet ihr einfach mal alle euer
Maul richtig gut
oder ja konnte ich
nicht heute nehme ich euch mit dem
Privatchat mit nach Griechenland dort
hatte ich nämlich ein extrem wichtiges
und erfolgreiches Meeting als erstes
habe ich mich fresh gemacht und es wurde
gefrühstückt mit dieser atberaumenden
auss ich kann SAS nicht angucken bei mir
das so komplett ab auch so ja okay wenn
du privat Jet fliegster zeig das doch ke
ich hatte heute heftiges direk
ze w direkt so ein Video machen genauso
als würden wir
machen man sieht aber auch dass der
Schuh Fake ist weil bei diesen
originalschuh kann man die nicht so
hochziehen
danke
Bruder so dumm so dum ein Milchshake
Vanille Vanille fünf mal sage ich dir
Vanille Vanille Vanille Vanille Vanille
Vanille Vanille Vanille nicht Erdbeere
ja danke
schön vanillehake oder
erdbeersake wir nehmen als Beispiel
15-
8 das jetzt ganz einfach wer es nicht
kann ist ein Lutscher guck z.B 5- 8
fangen wir hier an bei Klein 5- 8 geht
nicht weil ist größer als 5 das heißt
wir leihen was von Zehner dann ist es 15
ganz ein
alles hier rüber schreiben es ist ganz
einfach geworden weil
wir was habe ich jetzt
[Musik]
gemacht
paar Meter vorbei warum hängt der Papa
Platter wie Papa Platte oh mein Gott
what the [__] diger das ist jetzt mein
dritter Versuch diger und der letzte
diger ich will es unbedingt schaffen
diger diger irgendwie muss das Gehen
diger irgendwie muss das Gehen diger
irgendwie werde ich das auch hinbekommen
diger Bruder ich krieg ein Knacks diger
ich krieg ein Knacks diger diger das ist
nicht mehr normal dier wie sagt der dier
aber ich glaube wir sagen es auch schon
sehr häufig oder in jedem Satz bei mir
ist dier wie KST du die Dame mit so
Döner bin leider
Vegetarierin du siehst deinen Vater nach
5 Monaten das erste Mal
wieder Mo
moin s neu Spielzeug in diese Avocados
reinmachen dieser Holzball der da drin
ist geht mir voll auf die
Nerven und an der Stelle wür s noch
nicht die heutige nicht lachen Challenge
dann auch beenden wie bereits zu Beginn
gesagt seh sehen sehen
gehen ja